[Music]
have you finished the conquest
not yet decide why do you summon me
i bring news before mighty dark side
came to the throne
he searched the universe for the
ultimate weapon
the anti-life equation the key to
controlling all life and all will
throughout the multiverse
he found it hidden on a primitive planet
but before the story of the defiance
is well known i have found the primitive
planet
the world has fought back it is earth
the anti-life equation is carved into
the surface
of this very world
are you certain i have seen it i have
looked
with my own eyes
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my lord
so begins the end
maybe one
is back
i spent a lot of time trying to divide
us
i made a promise to him on his grave
i need to bring us together
there are enemies coming from far away
they serve an old power
this world is divided
no protectors here no lanterns
no kryptonium it will fall
in his name
i have turned worlds to dust
all of existence shall be
mine
i have a second chance i am not gonna
waste it
he said the age of heroes will never
come again
fighting the devil in his army
you know i don't care how many demons
has fallen how many hells
he's never fought us united
it's time to stand
[Music]
fight
the time is now
[Music]
you